xavier riches est professeur d'économie
spécialiste de la chine bonjour et merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
comment analysez-vous cette dernière
sortie de donald trump est ce qu'il peut
réellement faire payer la chine a écouté
il ya plusieurs interprétations la
première sinon c'est aux politiques
c'est à dire nous présentera fait face
disons à ce problème qui se développe
aux états unis et sur lequel ils réagir
les motards et qui se trouve fortement
touchée parce que c'est le pays où il ya
aujourd'hui le plus de morts ça c'est un
premier point deuxième point c'est un
argument aussi politique dans le sens où
c'est un dérivatif par rapport à cette
impuissance à juguler la question alors
la question qui se pose c'est sur le
plan juridique je vois pas très bien
comment on pourrait être faire un procès
à la chine que l'instance ce pourrait
être mobilisé sur quelle tribune à quel
type d'accord pour être fait ça c'est un
problème absolument
comment dire qu'ils ne reposent pas sur
des faits j'avais dit que les sur des
institutions intentionnel qui pourra le
faire et j'ai ma connaissance que j'ai
jamais entendu parler de problèmes de ce
type alors il est vrai que aujourd'hui
les états unis d'autres pays également
et essaye de comment dire de freiner un
peu ce qu'on appelle le soft power
chinois on a dit récemment que la chine
avait tiré profit de la façon dont les
vnf fin à l'épidémie chez zen pour
montrer que finalement elle était
capable de cocon circonvenir 7
cette épidémie d'une part et se faisait
fort de venir en aide pour donner des
conseils auprès des états qui en ferait
la demande
et c'est même me dire oh proposé de
faire dix ans de l'envoi de masquer un
peu partout dans le monde entier et
paradoxalement d'ailleurs et ça c'est un
des paradoxes de cette crise et que la
chine ne redevient l'atelier du monde ce
qu'elle voulait éviter d'être puisque
c'est le pays qui produit en masse
disons des masques qui produit des
dépassements de protection personnelle
quels livres disons au monde entier des
firmes d'ailleurs coopération mais aussi
des fake l'entreprise on sait qu'une
grande partie des points tim enfin une
partie des produits qui sont exportés
par la chine sont de très mauvaise
qualité ce qui se retourne un peu contre
cette politique de soft power
développé par la chine alors donald
trump un reproche on l'a entendu aux
chinois une mauvaise gestion de
l'épidémie à ses débuts pékin est
également pointée du doigt par d'autres
pays qu'elle pourrait être selon vous
les répercussions sur pékin à la suite à
la sortie de la crise
le problème c'est que pékin va se
trouver il va être la pression ça c'est
une ode un autre aspect assez
intéressant puisque d'à côté que je les
dis elle sortait conforté la plaint de
la manière dont elle avait conduit la
ville contre cette épidémie
mais aujourd'hui les accusations qui
sont portées contre elle alors qu'elles
soient fondées ou non c'est autre chose
mais pointe sur des problèmes très
importants c'était le retard où on
estime qu' il ya un écart entre de 46
jours entre le moment où on à nous
relever un peu des premiers symptômes de
cette maladie des décisions
massi brutale qui ont été prises par le
gouvernement chinois pour quand vous
dire fermez la ville de montréal et
lutter contre relation de de l'épidémie
alors c'est sûr qu'aujourd'hui il ya une
demande d'explication comment le système
s'il a été disons fougueusement
il a été capable de juguler le début des
niveaux local a été tardif pour exprimer
ce qui se passait et toujours aussi
hésitant à donner toutes les
informations confirmant sur disons
comment il a traité est découvert tous
eu cesse de cette maladie alors ça je
crois que c'est une pression qui pèse
sur les chinois mais disons que d'aller
jusqu'à exiger des remboursements au nom
pas très bien comment ça fiscale merci
beaucoup à xavier riche et professeur
d'économie spécialiste de la chine merci
d'avoir répondu à nos questions merci à
vous